في الحرب. وخدعة امريكية خبيثة
تزعج الاوكرانيين. وباكستان
تتحدى عقوبات الغرب مع روسيا
وصواريخ بوتين تصل الى مولدوفا
والرئيس الفرنسي يقطع وعدا
للشعبين الاوكراني اصحاب العيون
الضيقة يرعبون امريكا والخوف
يتسلل لقلوب اليابانيين ليطلقوا
بعدها صافرات التأهب العسكري
بينما الاستخبارات الصينية تحرج
الاوروبيين وكوريا الشمالية تكرم
جيرانها باكثر من مائة قذيفة
ليقولها المجنون اذا اردتم فهناك
المزيد تركيا تعلنها لليونان.
تراجعوا والا سنعمل ما يمليه على
الواجب العسكري بينما يعطي
اردوجان مهلة لواشنطن وموسكو
والامارات تضع الملح في الجرح
العربي. النيران الاوكرانية
تخترق الحدود الروسية. صمت
الاوكراني لن يطول وكييف تعلم ان
خير وسيلة للدفاع هي الهجوم وقد
حان وقتنا لنهاجم كما تقول
اوكرانيا. وبعد ان اعلنت الدفاع
الروسية ان قاعدة جويتين روسيتين
تقعان في وسط البلاد تعرضتا
لهجمات نفذتها طائرات مسيرة
اوكرانية هي مسيرة اوكرانية اخرى
تستهدف مهبطا للطائرات في منطقة
كوريسك الروسية المحاذية
لاوكرانيا. والمراقبون يقولون ان
كل ما يقع ضمن مدى الف كيلو متر
في روسيا سيكون هدفا محتملا
لاوكرانيا. فهل تدخل الحرب طورا
اخر هذه الضربات ليخرج مسئول
السياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزي بوريل مصرحا.
موسكو لا يمكنها ان تنتصر في
الحرب لكن يمكنها تدمير
اوكرانيا. موضحا ان الخروج من
الحرب يجب ان يكون باحترام
الشرعية الدولية. كما شدد بورين
بان حل الازمة يتطلب حتما تقديم
ضمانات امنية لاوكرانيا. اما
بالنسبة الى ضمانات مماثلة
لروسيا فمسألة يتم البحث عنها
لاحقا بحسب تعبيره. ليأتي الرد
الروسي على لسان وزير الخارجية
الروسي سيرجي لافروف ان حلف
الاطلسي يشكل تهديدا خطيرا
لروسيا وان مواقف الغرب تعتبر
انتحارا وقد تؤدي الى صدام مباشر
بين القوى النووية وستكون له
عواقب وخيمة. يبدو ان صبر الروس
قد نفذ يا سادة لتفرغ موسكو على
اوكرانيا باطلاق وابل من
الصواريخ التي تسببت في انقطاع
تام للكهرباء هناك اكد زينيسكي
ان قوات بلاده اسقطت معظم
الصواريخ الروسية وان الكهرباء
تعود تدريجيا. لكن سلطات كييف
كانت قد اعلنت ان صواريخ روسيا
متجهة نحو العاصمة الاوكرانية
ناصحة السكان بالتوجه الى
الملاجئ فورا. صواريخ روسيا خارج
اوكرانيا مرة اخرى بعد بولندا.
حيث افادت تقارير حكومية في
مولدوفا بان صاروخا روسيا اسقطته
الدفاعات الجوية الاوكرانية سقط
بالقرب من بلدة برشيني شمال
البلاد لتصبح مولدوفا الضحية
الجديدة لصواريخ بوتين الغاضبة.
اما الهدف القادم لصواريخ موسكو
فربما تكون اليابان. حيث نشرت
روسيا صواريخها بالقرب من جزء
المتنازع عليها مع طوكيو. جاء
ذلك بعد يوم واحد من اقرار طوكيو
ميزانية دفاع ضخم. وبالعودة
للحرب الاوكرانية. كشفت صحيفة
الامريكية عن خدعة امريكية
للاوكرانيين. فبعد تحذيرات موسكو
عدلت واشنطن سرا المدى الخاصة
بصواريخ هايمرس المرسلة الى كييف
حتى لا يمكن ان تصل الى الاراضي
الروسية اجل منع توسع الحرب مع
موسكو. بينما ذكرت صحيفة
النيويورك تايمز الامريكية ان
روسيا تمكنت من صناعة صواريخ
كروز خلال الاشهر القليلة
الماضية رغم العقوبات وهي
الصواريخ التي استخدمتها لقصف
البنية التحتية في اوكرانيا. ومن
حرب الصواريخ الجوية الى الحرب
النفطية حيث تتجه روسيا لتخفيض
انتاج النفط ردا على تحديد سقف
لاسعار النفط من قبل وسيؤدي ذلك
الى قفزة لا يمكن تخيلها في
الاسعار العالمية كما قال
المتحدث باسم الكريملين ديمتري
بيسكوف ليضيف قائلا روسيا لن
تعترف باي سقف للاسعار. واكد ان
موسكو تجهز ردا مناسبا للاتحاد
الاوروبي وان العقوبات على روسيا
تلحق ضررا واضحا باوروبا. لتعلن
باكستان عن اتفاق جديد مع روسيا
لشراء الروسي بسعر مخفض. وقالت
الحكومة ان موسكو دعت اسلام اباد
لبدء مباحثات بشأن عقود طويلة
المدى لتوفير الغاز الطبيعي
المسال. وبين هذا وذاك تقارير
غربية تفيد ان الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكون يعتزم الاتصال بزيليسكي ثم
بوتين لبحث انهاء الازمة.
والمستشار الالماني شولز يؤكد ان
بلاده جاهزة لتكون ضامنة لاي
مستقبلي لوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا.
الصين تصيب واشنطن بالجنون.
الصين تتلاعب باعصاب الامريكان
وواشنطن تفعل ما بوسعها لايقاف
الصينيين ولكن الدليفري الامريكي
لا يتوقف. هنا الادارة الامريكية
تعلن عن صفقة بيع اسلحة لتايوان
التي تحتوي على مائة من صواريخ
باتريوت الاكثر تقدما بحسب وكالة
رد بكين جاء برفض وزارة الدفاع
الصينية تقرير البنتاجون بشأن
وتيرة برنامج الاسلحة النووية
الصينية واصفة اياه بانه تخمين
عبثي وغير عادل ومتهمة الولايات
المتحدة بانها اكبر صانع للمشاكل
ومعتبرة ان امريكا تجلب الكوارث
اينما حلت. لاول مرة اواثقكم
الرأي. المجنون جيرانه. الجيران
يغضبون مجنون كوريا الشمالي.
ليوجه كيم قوات ووحداته العسكرية
باطلاق وادي من قذائف المدفعية
في البحر بحسب ما ذكرت وكالة
الانباء المركزية الكورية
الشمالية ليكون هذا ردا على
المناورات الجارية في كوريا
الجنوبية بمشاركة الولايات
المتحدة. لتصف سيول ذلك بانه
انتهاك لاتفاقية الفين وثمانية
عشر بين الكوريتين للحد من
التوتر ليعلنها المتحدث باسم
الجيش الكوري الشمالي قائلا يجب
على العدو ان يوقف على الفور
عملياته العسكرية والاستفزازية
في المناطق القريبة من الخطوط
الامامية. صواريخ ومقذوفات كيم.
اجبرت اليابان على اتخاذ خطوة
عسكرية ستكلفها المليارات حيث
امر رئيس الوزراء الياباني
بزيادة قياسية في الانفاق
الدفاعي. وبحسب بلومبرج فان هذه
الزيادة تمثل نسبة سبعة وخمسين
في المائة مقارنة بميزانية
الدفاع في السنوات الخمس الاخيرة
والتي تبلغ سبعة وعشرين تريليون
ونصف الترليون دولار. وبعد خطط
الزيادة هذه اليابان تتخطى فرنسا
وتقترب من روسيا في الانفاق
الدفاعي. كل هذا الانفاق
الياباني على التهديدات
الاقليمية من كوريا الشمالية
المسلحة نوويا. تركيا تطلق
مهلتها الاخيرة. ربما يمنحك
القدر احيانا فرصة قد تكون
بالنسبة لك حلما ويجب ان تستغلها
قبل ان تصحو. هنا وزير الخارجية
التركي مولود جاويش اوغلو يقول
ان فنلندا يجب ان ترفع حظرا على
بيع الاسلحة الى انقرة كشرط
لحصولها على دعم لمحاولتها
الانضمام الى حلف الناتو. ويبدو
ان فنلندا ستستجيب لطلبات
الاتراك بحسب التقارير. فلن يعد
لديها خيار اخر لتنضم للناتو
هربا من الدب الروسي. شروط انقرة
تتطاير يمنة ويسرة. حيث افادت
مصادر تركية بوضع انقرة شروطها
للعدول عن العملية العسكرية
الشمالية السورية. حيث اعطى
الاتراك مهلة زمنية الامريكي
والروسي لاخراج قوات سوريا
الديموقراطية من منبج وتل رفعت.
ولن يتم تمديد المهلة الزمنية
بحسب ذات المصادر. فمن اين يستمد
الاتراك شجاعتهم هذه? لتكشف
مصادر دبلوماسية عن تحركات روسية
لعقد مصالحة بين اردوغان والاسد
ودور ايراني لمنع هذا التقارب.
فمن سيحقق اهدافه اولا يا ترى?
الاحداث والتطورات. رئيس
الامارات يبحث مع نظيره
الاسرائيلي تعزيز التعاون
الثنائي وقضايا ذات اهتمام
مشترك. وماذا عن الاشقاء
الفلسطينيين يا ابناء زايد فشل
شاب في بريطانيا بسرقة تليفونات
كما فشل بالهروب ايضا لكن اصحاب
المحل المسلمين تركوه وشأنه ثم
ارسلوا له رسالة. اذا كنت تحتاج
شيئا تعال سنعطيك في واقعة غريبة
الشرطة الامريكية تعلن القبض على
مطلوب للعدالة وتشكره لانه
ساعدها بالقبض عليه. على غير
العادة بدأت كورونيا بالهجوم.
فهل تستمر بذلك ام ان للدب
الروسي رأيا اخر?